we are taking a closer look at language
today and how some languages are under
threat with fewer people speaking them
and this is driven by politics that
should resonate across many parts of
Asia specifically we will focus on
Cantonese spoken by 80 million Chinese
around the world Beijing favors Mandarin
another popular Chinese language as the
official language of China for all 1.4
billion people which means other
languages within its borders including
Cantonese are in Decline that has
stirred some people to try to preserve
the language and is in the United States
of all places where that's happening
this school in San Francisco is offering
classes in Cantonese the prevalent
language spoken among the Chinese
diaspora in the city
[Music]
despite having a long waiting list the
principal is worried about the future of
her mother tongue
Cantonese is such a rich diverse
rigorous language
and then with an attempt to
um
sort of eliminated it is very sad
she's referring to a shift in her
hometown Hong Kong here Cantonese is
still used by 90 of its population but
Mandarin a variety of Chinese
standardized and promoted by Beijing is
becoming more common on the streets
more Mainland Chinese have settled in
Hong Kong without speaking the language
this in addition to the local
government's policy to favor Mandarin in
schools
the situation is even more acute next
door in Guangzhou
and the beijing's push for linguistic
Unity Mandarin became the dominant
medium of instruction in schools and
many citizens preferred language of
communication
which is worrying like in the past like
um like people from everywhere who came
to Guangzhou Guangzhou would be able to
speak Cantonese uh uh because of the
peers that peers would teach them the
peers would teach them Cantonese in the
past but now only Cantonese families can
pass on the language to the kids
back in San Francisco the language is
also a less favorable choice for many
students eager to learn Chinese
mentoring classes are far more popular
because it seemed to be better for doing
business in China
most of the students here learn
Cantonese for family reasons
my dad speaks Cantonese my family speaks
Cantonese and you know I never really
learned it fully growing up and wanted
to be able to have conversations with my
grandma
into City's famous Chinatown these
Cantonese speakers are well aware of the
danger their lingo is facing
they're trying to use it whenever they
could so their culture can be preserved
for as long as possible
[Music]
to get into this a bit more joining me
now in the studio is DW reporter hang
Shun Lee who speaks Cantonese and
actually both of us speak Cantonese
although yours is much better so for the
viewers who don't speak this language
why is this a big deal well Melissa
we're talking about a language that is
spoken by 80 million people so it's not
really just as minor dialect in China
and it's an extremely common Chinese
language among the Chinese communities
in in the UK or in the US for example
because of early immigration patterns I
mean as a U.S citizen you probably can
confirm that yeah I mean people in
Malaysia Singapore and Indonesia right
also will hear this language yeah
exactly because it also used to be a
business language in Southeast Asia so
that's why some elderly people in
Malaysia for example still speak the
language and historically it's also been
said that Cantonese is a much older
language it's thought to have been
originated in about 220 A.D in it's much
closer to the ancient Chinese language
that people used to speak during that
time and meanwhile Mandarin was recorded
in about like fourth the 14th century I
think and it only got populated across
China by the Communist party after it
took power in 1949. I mean so that's a
thousand year difference and uh it's
then Mandarin in that context is is
pretty new so just how different are the
two languages well they sound completely
different now um to give you an example
um let's say DW is the best news channel
to watch right in Mandarin it would be
DW should say how can this human tie and
in Cantonese it's DW High Joe
I mean it sounds really different to my
ears yes they are different and in fact
Mandarin and Cantonese both have
completed different sets of Grandma
rules and vocabulary so if one only
speaks Cantonese he or she would not be
able to understand a mandarin speaker
and vice versa and by the way there's
always been a debate about whether
Cantonese is a dialect of Mandarin or
not a linguist would say that no there
are two separate languages because
they're not mutually intelligible but
actually within mainland China it's
politically correct to refer to a
different Chinese languages including
Cantonese and Mandarin as dialects and
just to give viewers a sense um it's
actually more an unintelligible between
say Portuguese and Spanish speakers
sometimes can understand each other
these two languages are far more distant
well yes or more or less yeah I would
say more or less the same like as
Portuguese in Spanish or German and
Dutch for example and a little bit maybe
a little bit more um this information
now beijing's decision to elevate
Mandarin has had an impact on Cantonese
so how is that playing out in China
these days well it has received some
like it has drawn some backlash for or
like for two times already and just very
recently there was an outcry on China's
most popular video platform though in
which is Tick tock's sister app and
their Cantonese speakers said that they
were quitting the platform because their
Cantonese live streams got interrupted
now here's a video a goodbye video from
one of the users
Funko
foreign
bye bye
now this video we just saw was later
posted on weibo which is another Chinese
social media platform and it got
widespread support from other users so
one user wrote for example Cantonese
cannot be dumped it's a living fossil of
the ancient Chinese language if
Cantonese disappears Chinese culture
will become even less colorful and
another user wrote don't give up your
local language that's real Chinese
Mandarin is just an emotionless tool for
communication
and of course there were others who were
being less supportive and critical so
one user actually asked so why not learn
Mandarin properly and others are being
very very analytical writing
um well they are betting the language
because the staff cannot understand it
and if there's extremist content and the
government demands accountability the
platform cannot provide it and I think
this what this user is trying to
illustrate is that social media
companies are increasingly Under
Pressure to control speech online and
having different languages would just
complicate their efforts right I mean
talking about control in China I think
it's worth mentioning to people
listening that it's not just Cantonese
in China That's facing problems uh in
fact Tibetan Mongolian uyghur they're
under greater threat within the borders
of China and I think it really
emphasizes to the extent Xi Jinping
wants this National Unity the singular
language so how do different languages
create unique identities well I mean
language is never just a tool for
communication it's always linked to a
local culture a local identity let's
take Hong Kong for example having a
separate language which is Cantonese
somehow reinforced the idea that the
city is different from the rest of China
and there even if Mandarin has become
much more common people understand it
much better than before a lot of people
are still relock to speak the language
because for them it's somehow a reminder
of what they call the mainlandization of
Hong Kong
ultimately how worried are you about
Cantonese or as a Cantonese speaker of
course I'm worried not just because of
the political pressure but a language
can also weigh when people decide to
abandon the language voluntarily because
another lingo gets more prestigious
socially and economically and I
certainly don't hope that would be the
case hunction Lee thank you so much for
joining us